hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar prepare your lab for flu season
with Multiplex PCR
I'm Angelina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more please visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
now I'd like to welcome our speakers Dr
Peter fried and Lauren Miller
for a complete biography on today's
speakers please click their names in the
presenter window at the top right of
your screen
Lauren you may now begin your
presentation
this talk we'll be reviewing this year's
viral respiratory infections from an
epidemiological perspective I'll start
with a brief update on the current
covid-19 situation and some important
considerations for preparing for this
winter season
I'll introduce some of the common
respiratory viruses before discussing
their clinical management and the
importance of diagnostic testing I'll
leave you with a final note on Multiplex
BCR technology before handing things off
to our next speaker
our first topic is a brief update on
coven 19. it's been over two and a half
years since the first reported case and
today the pandemic is still considered a
global emergency with high circulation
worldwide
currently Omicron continues to dominate
the globe with ba5 Omicron lineage
reflected in 90 of reported sequences
future waves of infection are expected
from different sub-variants of Omicron
if not a different variant entirely
that being said we're at a point now
where future waves of infection don't
necessarily translate into future waves
of death
today we're equipped with the knowledge
and the tools we need such as
vaccinations antivirals and case
management protocols to effectively
prevent transmission and severe disease
so now that we have these tools and
infrastructure in place how do countries
prioritize their policies when we seem
to be slowly transitioning from pandemic
to endemic but still face the risk of
new variants in future surges
to assist these National and Global
efforts the World Health Organization
released six policy briefs outlining
essential actions that policy makers can
Implement and according to their
recommendations testing systems and
strategies currently strive to meet
three main objectives one testing should
enable timely and appropriate clinical
management
two testing data should inform
epidemiological Trends which can help
direct isolation protocols in Public
Health and Social measures
in three testing strategies should track
the circulation and evolution of the
virus to detect increases in incidence
and emergency variants
tracking and trending disease
circulation is important for monitoring
existing respiratory viruses
interestingly when looking at these
epidemiological patterns in relation to
the timeline of the covid-19 pandemic
you can clearly see what a profound
impact the pandemic has had on the
circulation of viruses such as RSV and
flu
in the EU RSV was significantly reduced
during the winter of 2020 with an
unusually high off-season Peak during
the Spring and Summer wave of 2021. the
seasonal flu was virtually non-existent
in 2021 with a smaller and somewhat
delayed Peak last winter causing some
concern from experts for what this
winter will look like
these Trends give us a lot of
information on how non-pharmaceutical
interventions such as shutdowns and
school closures affect overall
transmission rates
para influenza viruses metanooma viruses
human coronaviruses and adenoviruses all
show significant reduction in their
circulation patterns throughout the
pandemic
in general we can see that public health
measures effectively reduce transmission
of respiratory viral disease but this
also decreases Community levels of
immunity
interactions between the SARS Kobe 2
virus and the other endemic viruses
whether competitive or cooperative are
very complex and might also
significantly impact the infection
Dynamics
given all the information we've just
discussed there are really three main
considerations when it comes to
preparing for this year's winter
first we all know how unpredictable
covid-19 can be when it comes to new
variants but experts are predicting
waves of infection by existing strains
this winter
second as public health measures
decrease and travel increases higher
influenza Peaks are predicted
record high influence activity in the
southern hemisphere this year could very
well indicate higher influencer rates
for us here in the northern hemisphere
and finally the co-circulating
respiratory viruses further complicate
the situation
based on observed epidemiological shifts
we've seen that easing social distancing
and other measures can lead to surges
and other infections these respiratory
infections can be exacerbated by
decreased population immunity due to the
lower exposure
at the end of the day understanding
these respiratory infections how they
present how they're diagnosed and how
they're treated will very likely be
crucial to managing this year's winter
season
respiratory infections are among the
leading causes of death and burden of
disease worldwide they can affect the
upper respiratory tract lower
respiratory tract or both
respiratory infections are typically
classified according to syndrome so the
common cold croup bronchitis pneumonia
Etc
this method of classifying and treating
a respiratory infection based on
syndrome alone is usually sufficient for
mild symptoms so for a healthy low risk
patient with common cold symptoms you
don't really need more information
before sending them home to get rest and
fluids
in other situations though a more
accurate diagnosis can be more effective
or even required for patient care
for example if an aminocompromised or
high-risk patient with asthma or COPD
presents with pneumonia you may very
well need more information before you
decide on the best course of action
for patients with severe disease
requiring hospitalization or mechanical
ventilation an accurate diagnosis is
critical for proper supportive care in
Therapeutics
another situation is during a local
disease outbreak or say Global pandemic
in which case accurate diagnoses are
required in order to inform isolation
practices and precautions as well as
Public Health and Social measures
unfortunately accurately diagnosing
respiratory infections can be
particularly challenging many
respiratory illnesses have very similar
and often overlapping symptoms and
patients can be asymptomatic or have
mild moderate or severe disease
symptoms can vary depending on a number
of factors the causative agent the
specific strain co-infection immunity
and General Health and to make it even
more challenging respiratory syndromes
such as pneumonia or the common cold can
actually be caused by a number of
different pathogens
since trying to work your way backwards
based on symptomology just isn't
feasible pathogen detection and
differentiation is key to understanding
respiratory infections while caring for
patients with severe diseases those at
higher risk or during disease outbreak
so what are these specific pathogens
we're talking about here
first there is of course SARS cov2
covid-19 can cause the symptoms listed
here to the right as well as long
coveted symptoms such as fatigue
depression or difficulty concentrating
a number of vaccines have been
authorized for use in the EU which are
highly protective against severe
diseases hospitalization and death
this virus evolved quickly and rapidly
making it necessary to adapt the vaccine
to match circulating variants and these
are provided as boosters
currently a number of antivirals and
other treatments are authorized for use
in the EU for the prevention and
treatment of copin 19.
next we have our influenza virus
influenza A and B cause the seasonal flu
with most cases presenting as
asymptomatic or mild but severe illness
can occur especially in elderly patients
children under five years old or those
with chronic medical conditions
influence viruses are also prone to
mutation with antigenic drifts and
shifts making it necessary to develop a
new vaccine each year
antivirals are available and recommended
for those at risk for developing more
serious complications
respiratory syncytial virus is a leading
cause of respiratory diseases globally
causing more than 3 million
hospitalizations and over 59 000
in-hospital deaths in children under
five years old
there's no vaccine for RSV but two
antivirals are approved for use in the
EU
the monoclonal antibody pallavismab does
not treat symptoms but is used to
prevent RSV infection in certain
high-risk infants
ribavirin may be considered for severely
immunocompromised patients with lower
respiratory tract infection
adenoviruses typically cause mild cold
or flu-like illness
more than 50 types of adenoviruses can
cause infections in humans most of which
are respiratory illnesses from the
common cold to pneumonia croup or
bronchitis
people with weakened immune systems are
at higher risk for developing severe
illness but as of now there is no
specific treatment or authorized vaccine
for adenovirus infection
human menanumavirus is a relatively
recently identified pathogen although
it's been thought to have been
circulating for more than 50 years
hmpv can cause respiratory disease in
people of all ages but especially among
young children older adults or those
with weakened immune systems
the human rhinoviruses are actually now
classified as being in the enterovirus
genus originally rhinoviruses were
assigned to their own genus since
disease presentation was notably
different but with the Advent of
sequencing based classification methods
it was shown that human rhinoviruses are
actually extremely structurally similar
to enteroviruses
human rhinoviruses are the primary
causative agent of the common cold this
infection is usually mild and
self-limiting but it can be associated
with bronchiolitis and infants pneumonia
in the in immunosuppressed it can also
exacerbate pre-existing pulmonary
conditions like asthma or COPD
enteroviruses affect millions of people
worldwide every year we're all familiar
with the polio enterovirus but there are
also 81 non-polio enteroviruses EV D68
being the one that typically causes
respiratory illness
most patients are asymptomatic or have
only mild cold symptoms but children
with asthma are particularly at risk for
severe symptoms from evd68 infection
human para influenza viruses or hpivs
commonly infect infants young children
older adults as well as those with
weakened immune systems hpiv 1 and 2
cause upper and lower respiratory
illness and Mild cold-like symptoms
hpiv1 is the most common causative agent
for croup in children hpiv3 is more
often associated with bronchiolitis
bronchitis and pneumonia while hpi4 is
recognized less often but may cause mild
to severe respiratory illness
with all of these different viral
pathogens associated with very similar
symptoms it's easy to see how
challenging it would be to make an
accurate diagnosis based on the clinical
presentation alone
pathogens are often associated with
characteristic clinical manifestations
so for example the most common cause of
influenza-like illnesses is influenza
virus
the most common cause of Croup is hpiv
while bronchiolitis is most commonly
caused by RSV
the common cold is commonly caused by
rhinoviruses as well as coronaviruses
and pneumonia is usually caused by
coronaviruses influenza viruses RSV and
adenoviruses
in many cases though these respiratory
syndromes can actually cause by a number
of different pathogens
so the clinical signs and symptoms of an
acute respiratory tract infection are
not necessarily pathogen specific an
accurate diagnosis therefore relies on
accurate pathogen detection
diagnostic PCR testing is considered the
gold standard for pathogen detection
in PCR genetic material is Amplified for
the detection of specific and targeted
organisms
the superior sensitivity of PCR can
detect low pathogen loads leading to
Accurate results early on in the
infection
diagnostic respiratory testing allows a
clinician to identify the causative
pathogen and from there direct the
course of treatment this can be critical
for high-risk patients or those with
severe disease
diagnostic testing also supports
antimicrobial stewardship and informs
patient management decisions such as
hospitalization isolation and follow-up
for example if a patient with severe
disease comes in and is diagnosed with
covid-19 they should have access to
oxygen therapy oral or intravenous
corticosteroids or other targeted
treatments
treatment for patients infected with
influenza is also specific to that virus
and is recommended within the first 48
Hours of onset of illness
infants and toddlers diagnosed with RSV
bronchiolitis can be treated with
barbavirin for these situations accurate
detection and identification of
pathogens is truly at the core of
treatment
diagnosis also supports antimicrobial
stewardship
antimicrobial resistance occurs when
bacteria viruses fungi and parasites
mutate over time and no longer respond
to medicines
AMR is a serious Global risk resulting
in over 1 million deaths every year
this crisis is responsible for a huge
portion of disease burden and an
infection with these resistant organisms
can be severe
despite the gravity of the situation
antibiotics are often prescribed without
a definitive diagnosis
during the covid-19 pandemic for example
widespread overuse of antibiotics was
observed for about 70 percent of
patients despite the fact that only
roughly seven percent of covid-19
patients were found to actually have the
secondary bacterial infection
so diagnostic testing can help
distinguish viral from bacterial
infections and lower the risk of
unnecessarily prescribed antibiotics
when coupled with good antimicrobial
stewardship
so we see the importance of accurately
diagnosing and differentiating between
these viral pathogens but running
multiple tests on each patient can be
difficult and time consuming
Multiplex PCR technology simultaneously
differentiates respiratory diseases
using primer and probe sets that cover
multiple targets
combining specific dyes associated with
each virus in a single reaction well
makes distinguishing infections much
easier and can help Physicians choose
the appropriate treatments
Multiplex testing is critical when many
infectious disease patients present with
similar symptoms
the covid-19 pandemic stressed the
importance of making effective molecular
Diagnostics accessible
the global Health response to covid-19
prioritized the implementation of this
infrastructure establishing PCR systems
which can now be used to address an
array of infectious diseases
Multiplex PCR can help detect
co-infections increase the likelihood of
an early diagnosis effectively identify
and contain potential outbreaks and
support clinical research and
epidemiology
at the end of the day there are so many
advantages using this Multiplex PCR
testing approach PCR is highly accurate
with high sensitivity and specificity
accurate detections can be made even in
the early stages of infections firm
samples with low viral loads and unlike
cell culture PCR doesn't rely on viable
organisms for detection
Multiplex PCR has fast turnaround times
with low Hands-On time rapid detection
of respiratory viruses can cut down a
patient's time spent in hospital or in
isolation
testing a large number of targets per
sample increases throughput and
decreases reagent use
Multiplex PCR is efficient and scalable
integrate and add to your molecular
testing menu expand disease State
Testing without increasing costs and
integrate with other automated
laboratory Solutions
Multiplex PCR can detect co-infections
as well as differentiate between viral
subtypes such as flua and flu B
multi-target designs can even compensate
for known emerging variants
so at the end of the day multiplexing
streamlines the laboratory workflow
while accelerating and improving patient
diagnoses
thank you Lauren now that brings us to
our first poll question for our audience
are you currently testing for
Respiratory pathogens other than coven
19. yes or no
we will give you a moment to answer as I
repeat the question are you currently
testing for Respiratory pathogens other
than covid-19 yes or no
now for our next question
do you want more information about the
Solutions in this presentation
yes or no
we'll give you a moment to answer as I
repeat the question do you want more
information about the Solutions in this
presentation
thank you to the audience
for your participation now I'd like to
pass it over to our second speaker Dr
Peter freebie for his presentation
thank you Lauren for this very detailed
and informative overview of viral
respiratory pathogens
and for highlighting the advantages of
using PCR testing
in the next 20 minutes or so I will
introduce you to our attack pass
molecular respiratory testing Solutions
which utilize Multiplex PCR
I will start by giving an overview of
all molecular Solutions and introduce
you to the tagpas covid-19 flow a b as
we combo kit
which you may already be familiar with
I will also introduce you to our latest
edition the tuck past respiratory select
Panner
I will then walk you through the
workflow of both nv2 diagnostic assays
and if you have used any of our covid-19
tests in the past the workflow will feel
very familiar
I will finish by highlighting the
performance characteristics of both
tests
and then we will open the session for Q
and A
so the attack pass covid-19 flow abrs V
combo kit can in a single test detect
and differentiate between SAS
coronavirus 2 influenza A B and RSV
it is designed to be scalable
so this throughput can be increased to
meet the demand
the test is highly sensitive and
specific for its viral targets
and it comes with our pathogen
interpretive software that will analyze
all the data and generate a report with
the result for each specimen
we offer the talk pass covid-19 flu abrs
we come book it in our 1000 reaction
packet configuration
and the kit includes all the primers and
probes to detect the wild targets and
the MS2 process control
the ms2-phage process control is
included in the kit and it needs to be
added to each sample prior to sample
preparation
this externally added process control
helps to directly monitor acid
performance of each sample
talking about controls the kit includes
a positive control
and the PCR is run using the tacpass
one-step Multiplex Master mix
the talk pass respiratory wire select
panel is our latest addition and can
detect five common respiratory viruses
in a single test
it targets adenovirus
human metanumovirus
rhinovirus enterovirus it does not
differentiate between the two and para
influenza virus 1 2 3 and 4 again
undifferentiated
the test is designed to provide for to
provide results of up to 94 samples in
as little as 2 hours
starting with nuclear asset it
complements our attack pass covid-19 flu
abrs we combo kit and both tests can be
run on the applied biosystems quad
Studio 5 PCI instrument
the tuck pass respiratory wire select
panel also comes with our pathogen
interpretive software that will analyze
all the data and prepare a report with
all the results
we offer the talk pass respiratory wire
select panel in a 200 reaction packet
configuration
and again the kit includes all the
primers and probes to detect the vial
targets and the rnas P process control
the rasp process control is sample
derived and does not need to be
externally added
monitoring rnasp helps to ensure sample
integrity and asset performance for each
specimen
a positive control is included in the
kit and the PCR is run using the tuck
pass one-step respiratory Master mix
okay now that I've introduced you to our
respiratory testing Solutions let me
walk you through the workflow
this slide shows a bird's eye view of
the workflow and I will discuss each
step in more detail but just to give you
a high level overview Step 1 is
receiving examples
Step 2 is sample preparation and nucleic
acid extraction
step 3 is setting up and running the PCR
and in Step 4 the pathogen interpretive
software analyzes the data and creates a
report with the results
okay now let's take a closer look at
each of the steps
both assets support mesopharyngeal swap
samples
collected by a healthcare professional
the samples are then sent to the
clinical testing Laboratory
the second step is sample preparation
carried out at The Clinical Laboratory
this is done using our Kingfisher Flags
purification system together with our
magmax viral pathogen two nucleic acid
isolation kit
the Kingfisher allows automated sample
preparation in 96well format
this extraction system is required for
the takbox respiratory vial select panel
and recommended for the talk pass
covid-19 flu a b RSV combo kit
the extracted sample is when used to set
up and run the PCR using the attack pass
respiratory while select panel or the
attack pass covid-19 flu AB RSV combo
kit
both SAS can be run on the Quant Studio
5 return PCR system in 96 well format
the attack pass covid-19 flow abrsv
combo kit also supports the use of the
Quant Studio 7 Flex real-time PC PCR
system for the use of 384 well plates
this allows to upscale throughput if the
need arises
the 7500 fast real-time PCI instrument
is also supported
for the talk pass respiratory viral
select panel the use of the quantum
Studio 5 and Quant Studio 5 DX real-time
PCR system is authorized
once a PCR run is done the pathogen
interpretive software analyzes the data
and generates a report with results for
each sample
the software monitors are that are the
controls performed correctly it monitors
the positive and negative controls as
well as the process control in each
sample
and of course the results can be
exported to allow integration into your
laboratory information system
okay now that you know the workflow I
want to highlight the performance of our
tests
I will start with the tag pass covid-19
flu a b RSV combo kit
the limit of detection highlights the
analytical sensitivity of our test
it reflects the lowest concentration
that is detected in 95 percent of the
testings
we determine the limit of detection for
each of the wild targets and it is
expressed here as tcid 50pml in the
middle column
tcid50 stands for tissue culture
infectious dose 50 and this is a measure
for infectious viral concentration
for SAS coronavirus 2 the limit of
detections are 8.2 times 10 to the minus
3 tcid 50 per ML and just to give you a
reference we use tighter around 10 to
the 6 tcid50 PML for the high tide
terrains though the title shown here are
extremely low
we also determine the corresponding
genome copy equivalent
chart GCE which for SAS coronavirus 2 is
50 GCE per ml shown here to the right in
the table
the limit of detection for influenza A B
is between 350 and 1250 GCE parameter
depending on the strain
and the limit of detection for RSV is
200 GCE per ml
the attack pass covid-19 flu a b as we
combo kit is a highly sensitive test
that can detect even low viral Titus
we also performed a lot of wet lab
testing to demonstrate that our asset
detect different strains and isolates
what I really want to highlight on this
slide is that we tested multiple H3 and
two isolates and successfully detected
all of them
I also want to emphasize that our test
can detect a recently reported H3N2
strain with a genetic genetic drift in
The Matrix Gene
detection of H3N2 is likely of
importance as this strain was the most
dominant strain in the southern
hemisphere
we also tested and detect the different
influence so B lineages shown at the
lower part of this slide
and we tested different rsva and rsvb
isolates and detect that all of them
successfully shown on this slide
now the talk pass covid-19 flow a b as
we come book it is a multiplex PCR assay
meaning that in a single reaction the
kit can detect and differentiate between
SAS coronavirus to flu a b and RSV
to ensure that there is no competitive
interference We performed a study in
which we added one virus at a very high
concentration about 10 to the six copies
per reaction
and the second virus at a very low
concentration just a few hundred copies
per action
to the left you see the amplification
curves for samples having a high flute
title and a very low SAS coronary is too
tighter
the amplification curve for the flu
Target is shown in red and it's labeled
flu High
the amplification curve for Source
coronavirus 2 is shown in green and it's
labeled covid law
as you can see both targets are
Amplified and detected
the MS2 process control is auto
Amplified and detected the curve is
shown here in plaque
to the right you see amplification
curves from samples with a high RS V
titer and a low flute tighter
and again both targets are successfully
Amplified and detected
the amplification curve for us V is
shown in blue and the amplification
curve for flue is shown in red
the MSU process MS2 process control is
shown in Black again
to conclude the tug pass covid-19 flow a
b is the combo kit is highly accurate in
detecting co-infection
and it is not impacted by high to low
tighter ratios
last but not least we performed a
clinical evaluation study in which we
tested retrospective samples with our
attack pass covid-19 flu AB RSV combo
kit against a CE ivd mark comparator
the results are summarized in this table
in the middle column you can see the
positive percent agreement short PPA
this number reflects the percentage of
samples that tested positive for the
respective Target using our essay in
relation to the comparator
as you can see we obtained a hundred
percent or very close to 100 for all the
three viral targets
to the right you see the negative
percent agreement which reflects the
percentage of samples that has the
negative for its respective Target with
our essay in relation to the comparator
and again we have a very close alignment
so overall this study demonstrates the
excellent clinical performance of The
Talk past covid-19 flu ABR as we combo
kit
okay now let me introduce you to the
performance of our attack pass
respiratory viral select panel
and again I will start with the limit of
detection to show you just how sensitive
our test is
we tested different strains of
adenovirus para influenza virus 1 2 3
and 4. human meter pneumovirus
enterovirus and rhinovirus
the limit of detection is shown in the
middle column expressed as tcid 50 PML
and just as a reminder tcid 50 stands
for tissue culture infectious dose 50
and it is a measure for infectious viral
concentration
the numbers we obtained are very low
and in summary the tech Pros respiratory
virus select panel is a highly sensitive
test
We performed in Silicon inclusivity
analysis to ensure that the test can
detect different isolates of the
targeted viruses
we analyzed over 1 100 adenovirus
sequences over 200 human meter
pneumovirus sequences over 500 power
influenza over 4000 entero and over 1
400 rhinovirus sequences
and our analysis found that we cover
almost a hundred percent of the analyzed
sequence the percentage as shown in the
right column
as with our attack pass covid-19 flu
abrs we combo kit the tag pass
respiratory wire select panel is also a
multiplex PCI essay that in a single
test can detect and differentiate
multiple viral targets
to demonstrate its ability to take
co-infection even with different tighter
ratios we tested samples containing one
virus at a very high concentration above
10 to the four tcid 50 per ML and the
second virus at a very low concentration
around three times its limit of
detection
our requirement was that the tackbust
respiratory wire select panel detects
both viruses and all tested samples
and that is exactly what our results
looked like both viruses were detected
in all 18 combination tested
with other words we did not observe
competitive interference for any of the
tested combination
to ensure that there is no
cross-reactivity we perform wet lab
stood studies using High concentration
for other organisms listed in this table
fire concentrations were usually above
10 to the 5 tcid50
or over or over 10 to the 6 cfu PML for
bacteria
cfu stands for Colony forming units and
it's a measure of bacterial
concentration
instead of going through each of the
organism tested let me just give you the
study results we did not see any
cross-reactivity the chuckbox
respiratory virus attack panel is highly
specific for its targets
we also performed the Precision study to
demonstrate that the test performs
independent of the laboratory the
operator or the time of testing
in this study we tested samples either
at a low or moderate while Tita at three
different Laboratories and two different
operators per Laboratory
each operator tested all three samples
on five different days
so overall We performed a lot of tests
and the column that highlights the
result is the percent agreement column
in this table which is the second from
the right
as you can see we are a hundred percent
agreement between all tests all Labs all
operators and all days
in our clinical validation study we
included a total of 350 samples that we
tested using our talk pass respiratory
wire select panel and the luminex NX
Tech respiratory pathogen panel which is
the ivd marked as a comparator
our study design had any sample with the
discordant results tested with the
biofire respiratory 2.1 panel and sorry
solver method
there is solver determines the true
value of a sample
finally having true positive and
negative values for each sample we
determine the clinical sensitivity and
the clinical specificity for our attack
pass respiratory wire select Panner
the result of the clinical study are
summarized in this table to the left you
see the viral Target with the clinical
sensitivity always the first upper entry
and the specificity just below
for example for Arduino virus we
observed understand the clinical
sensitivity of 100 and a clinical
specificity of 99.4 percent
overall we had very good agreement with
the True Values of each sample in many
cases at 100 clinical sensitivity or
clinical specificity or close to 100
percent
this study demonstrates the excellent
clinical performance of the tuck past
respiratory viral select Panner
so let me summarize we now offer the
tagpas covid-19 flu a b R3 combo kit and
the tag pass respiratory viral select
panel
to provide an all-around solution for
testing and differentiating between some
of the most common respiratory viruses
the attack pass covid-19 flu abrs we
combo kit can detect and differentiate
between SAS coronavirus II flu a b and
RSV
the takbox respiratory wire select panel
can detect and differentiate between
adenovirus
human metanumovirus
rhinovirus enterovirus
and para influenza virus 1 to 4.
you can add one or both kits to increase
your molecular testing menu
this concludes our webinar presentation
thank you for attending and we can now
welcome questions
thank you Peter we will now ask the
audience a couple more pulley questions
are you thinking of adding targets to
your molecular type testing menu yes or
no
I'll give you a moment to answer as I
repeat the question
are you thinking of adding targets to
your molecular testing menu
yes or no
and as a reminder we'll have some q a
right after this
now for our last poll question
do you want more information about the
Solutions in this presentation
yes or no
give you another moment to answer
do you want more information about the
Solutions in this presentation
yes or no
foreign
[Music]
thank you to the audience for your
participation and thank you Peter and
Lauren for your informative
presentations
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now and we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
let's get started
our first question
for Peter the TAC path respiratory viral
select panel says it targets rhinovirus
and and
enterovirus and differentiated what does
this mean and why is it done this way
so yes talk past respiratory
does Target rhinovirus and enterovirus
in the same channel both viruses are
very closely related they're actually
both part of the piconaviride family and
to maximize the amount of viruses that
we can Target we put both on the same
channel so that means that if a patient
is positive with either enterovirus or
rhinovirus especially antivirus D68
um the results will be the patient is
positive with rhinovirus antivirus
though the results are not
differentiated between those two viruses
great thank you Peter
um another question here for Warren how
does PCR compare to classical culture
and antigen-based methods
um yeah so
um classical PCR culture based methods
for diagnosis and antigen tests and PCR
tests they all kind of have their place
in the world of you know clinical
diagnosis and evaluation I guess antigen
tests you know they're very quick so
with an approximately you know 15 30
minutes they can be used to very quickly
test you know large numbers of people
screen their
um typically less sensitive than PCR but
the turnaround time can have a very
positive impact
um so you know this reason antigen tests
are usually used for screening nursing
homes dorms you know Correctional
Facilities homeless shelters hospitals
kind of larger populations to quickly
screen them to inform prevention and
control measures
um and control transmission
um but because antigen tests test for it
depends on the level of virus that is in
the starting sample there can be false
you know positives or false negatives
and
um
it's not as sensitive as PCR so PCR is
definitely considered the gold standard
for clinical diagnosis
and then when we think of cell culture
kind of these more traditional based
methods they can grow the bacteria
viruses and fungi but this kind of takes
a long time it can take a matter of days
or weeks they're also relatively labor
intensive and require a lot of training
for technicians
um it can fail when you're trying to
grow difficult to culture organisms like
fastidious organisms
um so in in comparison to cell culture
you know PCR and antigen testing are
both far more sensitive far faster
um the workflow is more uniform
um and it's a lot more accessible for
Laboratories
um so you know there's kind of a
trade-off for all all of these options
um but in general I guess the main point
is that PCR has much faster turnaround
times much higher sensitivity higher
specificity than cell culture
um and now it kind of opens the Gateway
for all of these New Paths for
Physicians to take so for example
syndromic panels you know they're
offered as multi-pathogen assays that
can detect co-infection in a single test
you can have custom ordered panels that
are really strategically tailored and
customized to meet a clinician's needs
and you know Physicians Now find
themselves in a situation where they
have this growing test menu where
testingperformed at clinical
laboratories can use a wide variety of
platforms all with very you know
straightforward and uniform workflows
for you know accurate results
um I hope that answers the question
okay thank you Lauren another question
for you we are warned of a twin democ
last year but it never came what makes
experts think covid-19 and the flu will
surge this winter
so the past two years I think we've
heard a lot of talk about this twendemic
which is basically you know experts
warning against
um large surges and coveted infection as
well as flu infection you know and kind
of this overwhelming of the hospitals
and healthcare providers because it's
all kind of happening at the same time
since flu is seasonal and you know as we
saw in the previous slides since the
public health measures and quarantine of
the pandemic have kind of
um
basically stopped the flu circulation
for a couple years while those Public
Health measures were in place
um I think the the worry was that once
we start moving around and traveling and
you know lifting these Public Health
measures we would all be sharing these
germs that we just haven't been exposed
to for a couple years
um this didn't happen the last you know
winter or two because we kept getting
more coveted variants and coveted
infections and we didn't really ease up
on covid restrictions as much as they
predicted
um so now it's kind of in full force
again this winter since you know
countries around the world are starting
to lift these restrictions we are
starting to travel more we're all
starting to kind of go back to the
things that we used to be doing
um so when you put all of that together
you know we do know that kovid is
expected to increase this year like we
said in the presentation you know the
new EQ one sub lineages and its
offshoots will probably
um you know cause at least you know a
relatively significant increase in cases
and at the same time experts do
anticipate a significant increase in flu
cases this year so you know since mask
wearing and social distancing are less
routine right now
um it's it's likely and a lot of places
I know here in the US we're already
seeing a surge in flu cases compared to
you know similar times in previous years
and the other thing is we can sometimes
use the southern hemisphere to kind of
predict what the flu will be like here
in the northern hemisphere since their
flu season happens first and when we
look at that for this year you know
Australia's had the worst flu season
they've had in five years
um so you know some experts are kind of
looking at that information and
predicting higher flu this year
um and then RSV that's kind of the the
third virus that we're expecting so we
saw in you know my last slide how when
RSV kind of had this giant
um increase last year kind of off season
um it's really showing how it's kind of
making a comeback in the EU and then
here in the U.S we've already detected a
surge in cases of RSV that's kind of
coinciding with Coba transmission and um
you know earlier flu season so
um that's I guess that's what we mean
when we say an expected now triple demek
it's with the addition of RSV into the
mix
um so I think that's that's where kind
of experts are looking at right now
thank you Lauren a few questions for
Peter now
um does the test detect all covid-19
variants
yes uh talk past covid-19 flu absv combo
kit does detect all covid-19 variants
all subvariants of omicons and we do
monitor all new emerging variants and
mutations and assess their potential to
impact very closely to ensure that there
is actually no impact on test
performance so our tests detect all
variants of covid-19 inclusive for all
subvariants of Omicron
thank you and a follow-up um just a test
differentiate between influenza A and B
the test does not differentiate between
influenza A and B and that's kind of a
follow-up on what Lawrence has mentioned
we do actually expect a peak of covid-19
flu and as we this winter or at least
there is a risk that all three viruses
will come up we have seen some early
warning signs so instead of
differentiating between influenza A and
B our test detects RSV on top of
influenza and SARS coronavirus two so it
tests for all those three viruses in a
single test
thank you
um and another question for Lauren is it
safe to get the covet and flu vaccine at
the same time
um yes it was the short answer
um so they've conducted a lot of studies
throughout the pandemic and the CDC has
um kind of some Publications that are
really interesting to look at but
throughout the pandemic they've been
testing the safety and efficacy of the
flu vaccine and the covid vaccine as
well as the coveted boosters
um and you know the most that they
noticed was a possibly slightly more
increase in initial reactions like
fatigue headache but you know it goes
away very quickly so the findings are
generally consistent that um there there
are no safety concerns with giving both
vaccines at the same time so yes
absolutely
perfect
um just last question here what do we
know about emerging covid-19 variants
such as BQ 1.1
um so bq1 and its sub lineages and
offshoots yeah they're they're making
their appearance known now
um the uh ecdc kind of projected last
week that there will be increased rates
um we'll definitely see increased cases
of these sublineages this winter
um I think the European Center for
disease prevention control they actually
released you know preliminary laboratory
studies that um estimate
transmission rates of these in cases of
these this winter
um but according to the very very
limited study
um it hasn't been associated with
increased severity
um so it's kind of you know it's
spreading relatively quickly but it
still kind of makes up a small portion
so
um that's that's on the radar for this
winter but um I think any other claim
would be
um I think we would just need more
information
um that that's that's something to keep
an eye on this winter for sure
hey thank you Peter and Lauren do you
have any final comments for our audience
uh not for me just thank you guys very
much for tuning in and um
yeah have a great rest of your week
yeah if you have any follow-up question
please feel free to contact us at Thermo
Fisher Scientific and we are happy to
answer any of your questions
thank you again Peter Lauren for your
time today and your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots in our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go I just like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any one of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye